[Music]
good morning everyone
we are coming to you with another gaming
in real life
video because we have once again
partnered up with global myopia
awareness coalition
we're joining their game on battling
myopia real life campaign a second time
exactly so the reason why we're joining
them again is to bring awareness
to you guys about myopia and in case you
didn't know what myopia means it
actually means
nearsightedness and that is when you are
able to see
objects very clearly when they're very
close but then once
like the object moves further and
further away it gets blurrier
and blurrier and this is actually a
condition that has
been growing rapidly in children and one
of their main
risk factors is actually spending too
much time in front of screens
and so for that reason we are once again
trying to pry this kid away from playing
his video games
by bringing one of our favorite video
games into real life and so this game
that we're actually going to be playing
is overcooked over yes so it's one of
our family favorites because
this game is like anxiety inducing and
you really have to
like step up your teamwork to make sure
that you get these orders out
done correctly and on time and so what
we're going to be doing is we're going
to be making
our breakfast so we're going to be
making oatmeal
pancakes and some eggs and eggs exactly
and so each order is going to be
customized to
our liking and so once we do that we're
going to be working together
to make sure that we get all this done
in a certain amount of time and making
sure that we get these orders done
right welcome to overcook
real life so for our overcooked session
we are going to be making breakfast as a
family and we've sent our time limit to
seven minutes so it usually takes us
about 20 to 30 minutes to make our
breakfast
leisurely with the pressure sentiments
we're going to be testing our teamwork
and our communication skills
and also we have a handicap and the
handicap
is this one spatula you're overcooked
you have like a
washing plate station and we're only
using
this one spatula for pancakes and eggs
which is a little difficult to consider
sharing a lot yeah so you have to wash
it every time
not just that but all of our
workstations or cooking stations there
aren't
one spot so the microwave is above the
stove
and obviously we need the stove for the
eggs and the pancakes the microwave is
for the
oatmeal and so just like with the game
as soon as the level begins initially
you don't know what stations you're
going to take if you're playing with
multiple people because
you kind of just have to figure out as
you go what the system is
exactly because every level like they
have different things like
things move around or whatever it is but
obviously nothing's going to move here
we decided we're not going to press
anything beforehand
and as soon as the timer starts that's
when we're just going to start pulling
things out of the fridge
mixing up the pancake batter whatever we
need to get out of the pantry that's
what's going to happen
so all my dishes need to be completed
and be correctly
completed in order for us to beat this
game
in real life hey siri set
timer for seven minutes
[Music]
all i know is i'm grabbing stuff out of
the kitchen i mean out of the fridge
oh
all right uh uh blue plates are for eggs
white plates white plates are for
pancakes
[Music]
mixing bowl mixing bowl pancake mix
yeah uh mixing bowl uh
all right who wants that to do pancakes
you do pancakes
i'll be pancakes which one's like
uh the the small one eggs
what do you want here uh i want a sunny
side of the egg
sunny side uh what else here
these are yours okay um
i'll get the i'll get everything what's
everything um
cinnamon brown sugar yeah and
blueberries
and bananas up there oh my goodness we
have seven minutes to do this
this is so hard oh my goodness
[Music]
[Music]
brown sugar cinnamon uh bananas and
blueberries
oh where's the spatula oh i can't have
it
the one that's the one spatula where's
the frying single tree
yeah i'll turn on the bed just at the
lowest one
banana blueberries blueberries
blueberries blueberries
uh how do i make pancakes i'll watch
blueberries oh okay
blueberries uh just a couple of them not
not all of it i love it okay
yeah grab a small bowl grab a small bowl
okay
yeah definitely watch out for that the
eggs
you want yours crispy uh
sure i hit your head
oh my hands are dirty
was it this one for the microwave
[Music]
[Music]
all right another egg
hey siri how much time is left
the time
oh
it's not cooking faster we're gonna get
at least one pancake in guys
yeah i'm doing all three oatmeal at the
same time nice
i only didn't two eggs all right you
might end up getting
very lumpy pancakes right okay cool
yes we're on the scoreboard guys for
pancakes we're on the scoreboard
i'm doing i'm doing the blueberries i'm
doing the blueberries this is the way
pancakes
yeah yeah yeah uh what type of eggs do
you want
scrambled okay
[Music]
washing
[Music]
right
oh can i borrow your spatula oh i gotta
wash this you gotta wash this
are you done with the eggs
[Music]
things do you want oh like
[Music]
um all my eggs yeah salt and pepper
right at seven minutes i have half a
pancake done
we have uh one oatmeal one oatmeal done
we have two eggs the name
two eggs good job eggs
this is a one star uh overcooked
braiding yeah i think we got one star
dang
should we show you ten minutes hey
thirty three
minutes uh what is it
three minutes all right we're doing ten
minutes down
all right so purple with your head i
think
your egg is almost done can you pass me
the pepper
pepper pepper remember yeah
[Music]
that looks pretty good
all right who needs help uh
[Music]
the answer yes yes siri how much time do
we have
siri hey siri
how much time do we have
[Music]
hey siri how much time
[Music]
hey siri how much time is left
[Music]
one minute 32 seconds okay okay
got this you know what though not only
are we making food
we're cleaning up after ourselves too oh
yeah that should count for something
oh look at that that's messy
yeah but it's so watery i put too much
milk on both the marks i like water
what pancake is this i don't know
if you want it you can have it here yeah
that one's
yours i'm making the last one this one's
daddy's this is mine
oh no no that totally didn't happen
we have so much more time guys there's
so much more time
yeah that's it and that's it
we're one pancake short one pancake
shorts
we had we actually had a little bit more
time than 10 minutes
oh
this is definitely still one star
maybe two stars two stars i like two
stars
three stars we passed the level like
perfectly
you know just one star we still pass the
level anyway
so we passed do you guys like overcooked
in real life better
or do you guys like overcooked on screen
better i like this better
yeah this is fun this is already working
it's like kind of like a workout at the
same time
it's still oh
because honestly i don't think these are
cooked all the way through
you okay
[Music]
you're the nine plates we did pretty
good
did you have a family
[Music]
but i wanted to ask you guys like how
have you liked this experience because
the first time we did
hello neighbor and then now we're doing
overcooked so do you think this is
a nice little break away from the screen
honestly yes
it's pretty fun like getting away from
the screens
because after a while it does get boring
yeah but the only thing we can do around
this time
is just play so it's actually pretty fun
to reenact the games we tend to have
fun playing and enjoy yeah that's true
and then we this time we all get to
actually be together and enjoy it
because even though we sometimes do
play video games together this is a nice
break for our eyeballs and
speaking of our eyeballs once again we
want to give shout outs to global myopia
awareness coalition for partnering us
with us in this video and to raise
awareness around myopia
so parents out there please do not
forget
how important those annual comprehensive
eye exams are for your kids
and because a lot of the times it turns
out that kids don't even know that they
have blurry vision they don't even
realize that they have developed myopia
so those
annual eye exams are very important so
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to comment down below if you guys
would like to see us do more of these
in real life video games because it's
actually really fun to
just do it and get to work as a family
it's really really fun so comment down
below any other games that you guys
would like to see us do
in real life and thanks for watching
make sure to comment if we got a one
star a two star or three star in our
attempt here just like an overcooked
how we did how to do anything we did
yeah and if you comment
one people who see that comment
uh type comment on their comments saying
type that in the chat in the chat if you
know what that means
you know you do know because we don't
know because i don't know but isaac
knows
what did you say we're old
[Music]